[Musique]
on ne sait pas moins ses médecins qui ne
savent pas écrire on ne comprend rien
pour écoutez je vous met entre copines
vous avez quoi anjema là d'accord
j'avoue quand
on regarde et des pansements c'est super
waouh 90 euros s'il vous plaît ah non 95
j'avais oublié la tva un
bon match avait facilité la tâche vous
comprenez je suis une femme de terrain
jordan vous savez vous connaissez très
bien white mike est parti à nixon teaser
[Musique]
là
m
[Musique]
et
j'ai ouï le soir quand tu retires ton
soutien gorge c'est ce que je vous
montre tessin
terrettaz qu'une petite alice asie je le
vois très très bien entre thézan
ta baguette magique non attends flamme
passe et qu'on membres il
a dit je vous l'amour c'est une montre
pour garder le prix
vous ne rêvez pas 607 1602 euros pour
combien tu réagis de payet et garde
un rythme de
nos
petites idiote
harry potter est mort
à partir de ce jour
vous mettrez votre foi
pour moi
harry potter humeau
et l'instant est venu pour vous de
déclarer votre foi
présentez vous et rejoignez novo
ouvrait
36,9 et toi
samedi qu'une [ __ ]